OK, guys, we have to start today with a very
real, very sobering conversation.
I wish we didn't have to have this conversation,
but I'm not going to blow smoke up down in
out of anywhere.
Maybe we can get something positive out of
it.
And I don't say that in a sort of coy or,
you know, kind of B.S. way, a teachable moment.
Like maybe we can actually get something out
of this because it's increasingly clear that
Republicans, if they choose to, if they decide
that the political risks are reasonable, are
going to have the votes to move forward with
a replacement of Ruth Bader Ginsburg on the
Supreme Court.
Yes, they are hypocrites.
Yes, they're completely ignoring the guidelines
they claimed were necessary in 2016 to deny
Barack Obama a Supreme Court pick to replace
the late Justice Antonin Scalia with Merrick
Garland.
But the reality is we have to deal with reality
that Democrats right now don't have a path
to stopping Donald Trump from replacing Ruth
Bader Ginsburg.
It will be up to Republicans.
Remember that the numbers are Republicans
have 53 of the 100 Senate seats.
In order to deny them the 51 or it's really
50 votes that they have to be denied because
even in a 50/50 vote.
Mike Pence gets to tie break and you know
how that will go.
We need to find four Republicans who will
refuse to move forward with a confirmation.
We heard from Lisa Murkowski from Alaska.
She is one such Republican who has said at
least not before the election, during the
lame duck.
Who knows?
We then heard from Susan Collins from Maine,
another Republican senator who says not before
the election.
No, but bear in mind, even if we wait it out
until November 3rd.
And Joe Biden wins these, same to Republicans.
Lisa Murkowski and Susan Collins may well
be willing to push someone through during
a lame duck period.
And in any case, too, isn't going to be enough
to stop it.
Donald, Mitt Romney, rather, is someone that
people have been looking towards.
Maybe Mitt Romney could be a third Republican.
As of right now, Mitt Romney has said it looks
like he's going to be okay moving forward.
And even if Mitt Romney could be added as
number three to the list, you need a fourth.
So the reality today.
Is we have to contend with this situation.
There is a very real practical lesson here
and it's a lesson to all of those people.
You remember them?
I remember them.
Some of them even have YouTube channels who
in 2016 were saying Trump and Hillary are
two sides of the same coin.
If it's Trump or Hillary, I don't care.
They're both corporatist centrists and it
really doesn't matter which one is elected
for the next four years or eight years.
And I mentioned the Supreme Court in 2015
and 2016.
As you know, some of these clowns, some of
them said Supreme Court.
It's not like Hillary's going to pick any
real left wingers to the court.
Well, Donald Trump stole one from Obama with
Neil Gorsuch, and then he got Brett Kavanaugh
to ludicrous ideologues, the likes of which
Hillary Clinton never would have even considered
putting on the court.
And now Donald Trump is on the verge of ingraining
the most conservative Supreme Court in a long
time by replacing Ruth Bader Ginsburg with
a straight up Handmaid's Tale right wing cultists
who I will be talking about later.
This is not.
I told you so stuff.
This is a learning experience.
This is learning from mistakes.
If we can learn from it now, if we can't,
then we arguably deserve what's coming and
what's coming could be very, very bad.
The Supreme Court did matter.
The people who wrote it off in 2016 and the
people who are writing it off right now in
2020.
They were wrong.
They are wrong.
Period.
Abortion rights are now going to be in question
partially because there were people in 2016
who mistakenly thought Trump or Hillary is
going to lead to the same results.
This is not about shaming people.
This is not about shame.
This is about.
Hey, guys.
Some of us questioned the importance of the
difference between Trump and Hillary in 2016,
not me, but some of us did.
This is about understanding that there are
things we can control and things we can't
control.
In 2016, we could control our votes in the
primaries.
Once Hillary was the nominee, we couldn't
change that.
But we could then control whether we voted
in November of 2016 and who we voted for.
And some people made the decision not to vote.
Some people who supported candidates other
than Hillary during the primary made the decision
not to vote or to vote for Trump or to write
somebody in or whatever.
And, of course, a whole bunch of other things
happened as well, which affected the results.
But it was ultimately 77000 votes in three
key states.
And now Donald Trump is going to get his third
Supreme Court pick in one term, possibly with
more coming if he gets a second term.
They were wrong then.
Many of them acted like spoiled children.
Then they're not the only thing to blame.
Of course.
But they were wrong.
The whole both sides are the same.
Ideology is an easy way for lazy people or
intellectually uncurious people to feel as
though they're above it all.
I've sometimes used the term enlightened centrist.
There's also these folks on the left and on
the right.
It's not just centrists and it has been a
disaster.
So, OK, it's almost October.
What can we control now?
We can control whether we vote in this election.
We can control whether Donald Trump gets four
more years and potentially one or even two
more Supreme Court picks.
And as a result, gets to set the country on
what will potentially be one of its darkest
periods, certainly of the 21st century.
But probably for longer.
And if you need any further words of warning,
let's discuss next who Donald Trump is considering
to replace Ruth Bader Ginsburg.
It's dystopian.
Let's discuss it.